is ill and worried
he says the medicines he needs to
survive are running low and he can't
afford to buy anymore
the 77 year old is one of thousands of
people in Ghana who invested their
Savings in government bonds
now they've been told they can't touch
their Investments
more serious than even putting a gun
the High Cost of Living and Rising
poverty have pushed ghanaians to take to
the streets demanding the resignation of
officials they blame for the country's
economic crisis
the government encouraged citizens to
invest in bonds so it could raise funds
but it ran out of money to pay them
today
critics blame the crisis on excessive
government borrowing Reckless pending
and Corruption
they say the economy is on the brink of
collapse and people are becoming
skeptical about the financial system
in December the international monetary
fund agreed in principle to a three
billion dollar bailout
but it will depend on the economy being
structured something most people believe
would lead to harsh outcomes for an
already impoverished population
times are hard we can't sell we can't
buy everything is expensive it's a lot
of hard work to feed our families it's
very stressful you go home looking tired
as if you went to war
as the economy slows factories are
shutting down and thousands of people
are losing their jobs
investments in new infrastructure has
also stalled as the government seeks to
meet the demands for a bailout
economies say this could mean more
people like Peter Kudzu will be unable
to feed their families and be unable to
afford any medicines they need
Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera